hello and welcome to another exciting
episode of Google developers live my
name is Arun Nagarajan and this is
Google Apps unscripted November 2013 and
we're actually coming live from our
Mountain View studios and I'm normally
out of the Google in New York office you
can see my shirt representing but we are
here at Mountain View and we actually
have a special guest Patrick ír who's
one of our Google developer experts
Patrick you wanna quickly introduce
yourself and Patrick Google developer
expert based out of India and the Google
developer expert on Apps Script
it's super nice to have Patrick here
Patrick's one of our gdes
and here for the gde summit so will we
have some pretty interesting things that
Patrick's gonna show off but we'll start
off with our sort of normal
announcements and we'll also save some
time towards the end for going through
the questions in Google moderator also
apologies for starting a few minutes
late just some technical difficulties
from our site so the first big update
that will kind of start talking about is
on our blog so if I just go over to my
laptop here kind of wanted to point out
this one this change in fact when in
yesterday hopefully you've been able to
take a look into this so Apps Script has
this capability called advanced services
and there are a lot of really cool
services that we exposed to this
capability analytics bigquery prediction
a lot of these very powerful api's and
in the past we kind of masked a few
things in the API where certain
properties were listed incorrectly as
optional and in an effort to really
reflect the realities we're trying to
you know say if it's mark require if
it's mark required in the underlying API
make it required in Apps Script as well
so you can see that there's some changes
reflected here the resource property is
something that you have to pass in so
the we have the old and the new map
being provided so it should be really
straightforward for you to make a change
we in fact if you made the change last
week we actually included some content
about
you could have pre-made the change but
that's not a huge deal you can kind of
go through just the regular changes this
week so apologies if this costs any
disruption but this is something that we
need to make in order to make this
infrastructure reliable enough for
adding new api's and more on that to
come the next thing that we like to talk
about is usually all of our release
notes - releases since the last time we
did Google Apps unscripted and the first
one in November 4th is actually pretty
big one we fixed a really nasty error
where libraries were occasionally not
loaded properly and we've made it much
more resilient and you should not see
errors around libraries being
unavailable anymore
we also made another fix where deleted
versions of the library were allowed to
be used as a reference so that should
make these cleaner on our end but it may
break a few things on your end
so please do make sure that if you
delete a version of a library your users
that use the library make that change as
well and the other fix that we made in
November 11th is also a pretty big one
there was an issue for some users that
use the lock service quite heavily where
the lock became unavailable for several
minutes in some cases several hours
it's a rare issue but it is something
that we were able to figure out and we
have fixed it so if you see any issues
with the lock service please make sure
to look into that issue and hopefully
you will not so a couple of big fixes
last month and and hopefully we'll
continue adding more of these fixes so
continue adding your features and issues
into the issue tracker for us to monitor
and fix these a couple of quick
announcements as well next this week is
actually Dreamforce here in San
Francisco area and I'll also be speaking
tomorrow at the event that's in San
Francisco Dreamforce of course is the
big annual salesforce.com
event and I'll be talking about
Salesforce calm and Google Apps and of
course using Apps Script so if you're in
the area I'm not sure there's gonna be a
live stream but definitely check
Vidia we'll make sure to post it and
share it as well and the last
announcement that I want to make a few
minutes to walk through was eric koleda
our colleague recently shared something
on Google+ around a simple survey we've
together for scriptdb we're really
trying to figure out scriptdb what the
use cases that people are using it
before what some of the positives and
the negatives of it are so that we can
figure out where to allocate our
resources and what to focus on it's a
very short form definitely please take a
few minutes to look through it it's if
you just go to planet legal comm slash
plus eric koleda
you'll find it it's I think it's like a
third for a recent post it's a short
form and a lot of a lot of you have
already posted and commented on my post
do take a few minutes to fill that out
it's very important that we hear from
you so that we can react accordingly and
we'll come back to we have a Google
moderator page we'll come back to this
but we wanted to spend a few minutes
first talking a little bit about some of
the cool things that patrick has been
building so Patrick I understand you
have a really interesting HR appraisal
system you've built in Apps Script so so
why don't you start kind of walking us
through it and talk a little bit about
what you've built absolutely so we were
we were given the challenge of trying to
build a performance system in under a
month management wanted to see this
particular system out quickly so
obviously with the team we decided to go
to the fastest prototyping system out
there which for us is Google Apps Script
and I have will change to the laptop I
believe it's on yeah yeah and so here we
see a scheme of all the various
components that we were able to use and
we we use spreadsheets for creating the
appraisal disallowed the HR team to be
in an environment they were comfortable
with so they did not need to exit the
Google Apps environment when we say
appraisal this is sort of individual
feedback and giving manager feedback to
a an employee and so on yeah this is
basically a system that was built by
our new VP of human resource and he he
wanted to bring his solution and he has
a very particular way of building
appraisals I say where we have basically
performance measures right and then we
get a score based on those performance
measures for each performance measure at
a regular interval we say whether we met
the requirement we exceeded the
requirement we were below the
requirement and while this is
interesting at the individual level it's
more interesting at the organization
level because now we get metrics at the
organization level to say let's say a
performance metric a performance measure
would be consistently replies to email
in a professional manner and then you
have a score for the enterprise and it's
okay so the enterprise is performing at
80 out of 100 of that got it and so then
you can really direct your your actions
so we put all the performance measures
in one spreadsheet and we pulled these
in each appraisal creation spreadsheet
and we were able to give one per team or
about 900 people in your organization
about 18 to 20 teams rather than build a
system which was going to go across all
teams in one go we were able to then
pilot it with the first three or four
teams and once we were able to pilot it
then we refined the data model and so we
used libraries for that so we have a
spreadsheet handle library which is used
by all the spreadsheets so that
basically we can do the change in the
code there and all the spreadsheets
inherit from that code that particular
library would then use another library
for its database and we started with
scriptdb because scriptdb is quick
efficient allows us to do rapid
prototyping on the data model we can
update that data model as and when we
want and then for so that's I'm gonna
prepare my appraisal I'm gonna say for
employee of type a these are the
performance measures that they need and
now on a quarterly basis I'm just gonna
as a manager have a tablet and walk up
to the employee and spend a 3 minute or
literally 3 minutes to do the appraisal
with him and give him that feedback and
so we used HTML service for that again
HTML service was able to use the same
library to
scriptdb and then we had you know a
tablet based a tablet based application
let's take a quick look yes that's
awesome yeah which one is it and that's
it
Wow and so we just fill this up scores
are calculated on the fly I call this is
all HTML service HTML service older way
great and this works on a tablet and it
works on this obviously and then you
save not sure that's gonna work because
I might you know okay it's been
successful and then at the same time
once you do that that sends it to a
report Handler and then you know you can
just see the email that's okay these are
your your your results and let you have
a spreadsheet here as well where all
this is maintained yeah and so each team
gets the spreadsheet where they're able
to pull the performance items so the
performance items are pulled here with
the import range another spreadsheet
cool and fills that up so everybody's
got the same performance items and
basically you create this for one
quarter and then you keep saving it on
every quarter so you don't have to read
with this form over and over again very
cool I think one of the most exciting
things that happened is though so we
released this this product to the teams
they did a couple of appraisals and then
we went to the CEO and he said well I
don't want this quarterly I want this
monthly and here we hit we hit the
limitation of scriptdb because the
maximum commit is 4k for the first and
then it's another 4k and so we were
hitting the 7k limit quite quite
frequently so the system when we went
from quarterly to monthly appraisals
broke down and so like the team came up
to me and said so what are we gonna do
and because we were using scriptdb which
is no sequel database the port to Google
App Engine was basically instantaneous
and if we look at and you designed it
smartly with the libraries yeah so all
we needed to do was to swap the library
here we have two
this was G this was the scriptdb library
so we see each function like get
employee and then we query the DB and
then if we go to the Google App Engine
implementation we have exactly the same
exactly the same signature so the API
was consistent so we just needed to do
the basically URL fetch we've got at the
top of the screen which are not screen
not seen the the secret key and don't
want to share that yeah we don't want to
share that god and then inside of the
spreadsheet handler we just included the
the library and kept the same identifier
we had known basically no code to to
change and I think we did this in a
couple of hours cool and you are calling
App engines datastore through URL fetch
we are doing that god I think we did
this before cloud before datastore was
released independently at the time we
were going to engine very cool very cool
thank you very much for that quick
demonstration hopefully that gives you
some interesting ideas and some of the
things you could pull off and also some
of the challenges that Patrick you ran
into so we're running short on time why
don't we spend a few minutes looking
through any questions and Patrick you
can help me answer any of these
questions with your experience in cello
so let's take a look let's refresh this
and let's see so given the vast
abilities of Apps Script what would be
the most efficient way to pull data from
Google spreadsheet and display it in an
on Google Sites HTML page serve HTML
Doc's were still a little lost so this
is certainly very possible it does
require some some amount of work in our
documentation page under HTML service
there is a best practices section
definitely take a look at that talk to
you through how you can best do template
at HTML and you know you've kind of
showed yourself that it is possible to
take data from a spreadsheet and show it
in a in a web page absolutely an HTML
document so it is possible it does
require some technical background and
work but you know it is certainly
possible so
we'll look to maybe have some samples
around this going forward how to add
custom properties to drive files today
this API is not there the there is no
custom properties API and drive but we
recommend you post this to our issue
tracker as a feature request and we'll
certainly consider this you can always
use the drive API directly through URL
fetch but that's much more complex than
needed let's see programmatically
convert a file to office counterparts so
there is an open issue on this as you
noted get as always gets it as a PDF we
are over aware of this issue but take a
look at the issue tracker find this
issue and certainly give it your stars
and and put a comment in there we do
look through which issues are most
requested and attempt to fix those so
please mark your vote for that
distributing app scripts quite difficult
so sort of mentioned it yes you're
calling them out by name so hopefully he
is watching and now it's it's we're
certainly working on it we have not
abandoned any plans or anything like
that it's just a complicated thing to
get distribution right you can imagine
that we have to make sure the
installation is very straightforward for
non developer consumer folks so we're
working through it it's getting there
you will hear more on this in the next
few weeks and we'll continue to keep you
updated
do you plan do you have to you have
plans to create service for Google+ for
business yes we are certainly looking
into this so this will be what they
already have an API Google Apps Google
app Google+ four domains and believe is
the API so we're looking into this and
again stay tuned hopefully we'll be able
to share some good news on this front no
particular date on this but we are
looking into it let's see here
would what would be the way or is there
a way to determine via the drive API or
other library or other which libraries
are attached to which scripts I see good
good question there is no way today to
look up library information on a script
I think it's a really good request
please log that in the issue tracker 232
can you shed some light on the team
behind Google Apps Script unfortunately
no we can't do that we don't do that
it's a it's not something that we really
share the the team is very engaged the
team is it's hard to you know describe
anything about our effort or time we
spend on it but it is it is an engaged
team as you can see fixes are coming
we're talking about improvements that
will be coming are there plans to
deprecated UI app bah blah blah yes
question is yeah this we've heard this
one before so we have not announced any
plans to deprecated UI app what we've
been mentioning consistently is we're
adding features to HTML service we're
making it faster that's the way forward
for more complicated
professional-looking apps UI app will
continue to work we will provide plenty
of guidance when we plan to change that
but UI app is we recommend switching to
HTML service there's lots of guides we
have on it will continue to improve the
documentation for it there's several
components that people have built with
HTML service that are not possible in UI
app so my recommendation is to switch
only because it's more powerful and
that's where the most the investment is
but UI app is still run you have any ink
you the best practice page is fantastic
place to look at I think when we was
initially published we looked at
templatized HTML a lot but with the best
practice if if you can not use
templatized HTML although referring to a
previous question
putting your spreadsheet in a
2-dimensional data array and then doing
it with templatized HTML is a very quick
way of displaying the data but that best
practice page definitely must be read
yes and it is a bit of a learning curve
I mean like any new technology there is
some training required but we think if
you learn HTML that's good for the world
beyond Apps Script so that's one of the
reasons why we like HTML service is that
UI app is pretty specific to Apps Script
it's harder for you to reuse that skill
elsewhere and Apps Script allows with
HTML service your you know the the world
of HTML developers a lot bigger more
tools out there more learning resources
as well so multiple calendars in the
same page and the grid view should be
possible there's nothing we do to block
that I think the rest is just some spam
alright so I think we got most of the
questions answered if not we'll be back
on the air again in the next few weeks
and hope to answer more your questions
but thank you very much Patrick it's
believed a pleasure yeah and if Patrick
flew all the way from India so we're
excited to have him on the air and we'll
continue to find more ways to have a lot
of you out in the community on air as
well let us know if you're interested
and thank you very much and talk to you
guys in December
you